[Music]
from an economic standpoint concrete and
masonry are going to be the choice as
opposed to steel
[Music]
typically a column will have vertical
big bars that run from the top to the
bottom what we want to see is another
reinforcing bar wrapped around the
outside of those big vertical bars
you've cast concrete into the form after
that cures and there's lateral loads put
on the building that column can Sway and
it can bend but it won't shatter because
of those those ties that are holding all
the bars in place
thank you
[Music]
they'll have the columns and they'll
have the beams at the floral level and
then that panel that square in between
they might just infill it with a masonry
which often is doesn't have any
reinforcing in it at all so when
everything is is Shifting back and forth
that square is trying to turn into a
parallelogram and that Masonry shatters
foreign
so there's two things that they need to
do when they put the masonry in they
need to put reinforcing bars all
throughout at a grid of reinforcing bars
so it's anchored to the columns and the
beams so it can't shatter and fall out
in addition to that they need to have
sheer walls in the building typically we
would want those to be concrete and
they're rigid and they will erase it and
stop the building from turning those
squares into parallelograms
base isolation is probably the best
system out there and what that does is
it at the foundation level the building
is released so that when the earth
shakes the movement of the building is
at a different frequency and so you
might get really fast motions at the
earth and the building will just kind of
go along slowly so you don't get those
inertia forces up in the building if the
building is important enough base
isolation will be used on the building
but it is expensive
foreign